今日はちょっと前に動画にしたと思うんですけども僕の指に関する動画だしたと思うん
ですよ
ああいうふうに変なのができた変なのができたと言ってると思うんですけどもレースの
指なんですけども
[音楽]
大変なことになってきました間違ってみてくださいもうなんか肉眼でもわかるぐらいで
パパってきてるんですよこれやばくないぞと言われていたもうなんか昔入ってたんじゃ
ねーかが出っ張って来てほらもうご覧くださいね大きくなってきたらウザと思って
爪切りとかで切ったりしてると断念ができちゃってハサミで切っても切ってもどんどん
生えてくるっていう子
出っ張ることあるってくれて各なってるんですよん
きも far
もうほんとキモいんですよやつ中に当たるんですよね豊富通すところで当たったりして
ちょっと何か正確には主将でかけている
大きさなんでちょっとグロいので1回病院に行って何とかしてもらおうと思っており
ます今日は僕の経験上だとこれ多分なんかいもう方子の命だってなんだよの女だっけ
なぁなんかそういう名前っぽいやつなんですよこれ
釣りをする時で機体小さぶっかけたりなんかするような規模する
ですけどね治療法は病院に任せるんですがちょっと本当にこのままだと生活に支障が
出るので今日は僕の指を面倒をしています
あっぴょこんっはいそれ
ゴリラクリニックに来ましたなんで脱毛ねすごい有名だと思うんですけども脱毛以外で
もいろんなことを言ってるみたいな
こちらでなくしていきたいとおもいます粋なさーい
[音楽]
宜しくお願いします今から視察です
実際にあっ
実際これはですねどういう穴こういう子は勝手にカウンセリングして何かをしたいと
思いますでは先発ません
あ
政権は笹
はいはい
発する音がしましたーー
始め様ですはいはじめ
はいみなさんの衣装たいとアップしろ仕上げました
指を使うということを
するとかで活動が変わりますね
8本来の交通であればあの十分
取り入れることはですあーん
a 棟本当なんですけれども電気メスというものを使ってそれを
決めす通常
シューズなんかでも皮膚を電気的に焼いているような痛いですか
えーとまず最初にですねはい客車まず移行し東庁舎でこの部分だけ一部分だけ
注射を打ちましたますよでがサード痛みは
何だろうただますが増えてくると崔氏の祖父はところだけなんです
とありますがスマートたへ行っている範囲
まあからそこまでの技術ではないと菜食ワゴンしたか
兵衛の皮膚が少しぼやけるような形ない
で皮膚が再生してくるように大体一週間位1週間甲斐あります
ほぼ the 指を切るって感じですかギュ企業を巻き切るというよりも表面だけ少し
焼くような
さーん
言い方を変えるというよう治療みたいな感じですね
着るといいますか部分的に
8少し
あ
ちょっとモルト授業キルってなんですよ
そうですね福祉子の傷をちょっと作るよーあーありがとう
はい
キルっても何かあなたは著者としてもはす
ねぇねぇまたイイがのガイドスーツっていうことですもうやめさせる奴だっ
[音楽]
明治末てますか
私は待っ水を急ぎだけさせて痛みあるんですがあそこのに切ってしまえばあの動物で
注射ですねそう
ちょっと細いようになります
[音楽]
が持っていいから初めて
最後にちくっとします
hee
[音楽]
あっはっはたくない
これで麻酔が効いてると思いますそれであの
もし50ちょっとでも痛みがあったんですよ
はいだないただければ分かり3時の向こう s 音ですから
痛くないんですかん
ん
全然痛くないん
ああああああ
me
[音楽]
ん
コリッコリ切れましたのでございますが降った
2型ありがとうございます最後は軟膏塗ってオシャレになりますのではい
[音楽]
まず指がしびれている
ん
まずは3試合でした
あえて上で東京の病院にで直してもらいました
前はテープ貼っててアレなんですけどもここですねちょっと違う滲んでるんですけど
もう末裔も切れてねなんかちょっとヒリヒリするようなんですけどもう全然そんなん
聞い
なる痛みではございませんあのほんと最初の抜粋がでちょっとチクっとしたくらいで
それ以外は全くいただけなかったんで全然余裕でしたあの
もっと早くな
押せばよかったん
me
あっはぁ